I was just communicating to you through
I blinky Morse code what did I say
you're a pervert hi my name is grace
Helbig no now you know your life is
different now man I've been making
YouTube videos for oh no math almost 10
years almost 10 years and I gotta be
honest it's tiring and sometimes makes
me mentally very burnt out and I start
thinking about other professions that I
might do if I wasn't doing YouTube and I
realized I wouldn't be good at those so
I thought let's turn this into a series
called why I can't be dot dot dot and
this inaugural episode is why I can't be
a teacher Academy were names okay who
has the answer to today's question yes
potato it's Patricia well you look like
a potato and I only really not a good
influence on youth in an unedited
environment now what no but we can't see
our books in the shop let's go first all
1,000 dicks potato I'm actually potato
opening I'm a British descent so I'm
very repressed emotionally which means I
have a hard time communicating any type
of concerns excuse me you guys how like
do you think I might people get a letter
of recommendation from you P okay no to
Stanford what I'm applying to Stanford
University you are I am yes again at all
very good letters but you're applying to
Stanford yeah is there something wrong
with that no I feel like you're lying I
feel like you should suck a thousand
dicks what I only run away from conflict
lastly and most importantly I'm not good
at explaining complex matter in a
simplified way so as you can see e
equals MC
where any follow-up questions yes the
potato well what does that mean I think
it's pretty obvious um e equals
mc-squared
you just turned the equation into a dip
yeah well you've been stuck a thousand
of them potato but you're sure you
didn't eat a dick eat all eat dick okay
go there are just a few reasons why I
can't be a teacher let me know if you
agree or disagree don't forget to click
Subscribe I make videos Monday Wednesday
and Friday sometimes and click that
little Bell notification so that you
know when I make videos because I don't
ah don't do it regularly so at your own
convenience it's better to have that
Bell notification turn-ons you're
alerted so you don't have to wait up for
hours and hours because I know you're
all desperately waiting for my video
other than that thank you for watching I
don't know
[Music]